place here in egypt hopefully we can
utilize this space
when i see that i just see it's like a
typical white family and it's
just i don't i would never ever think
about what's about what they're about to
say never
spirit of the devil he basically made
his throne
here the the how powerful that is that
the very enemies who are hostile towards
islam are
crumbling on rooftops wow yeah i love
that yeah
check out our sponsors nature's blend
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
your brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are one inshallah
welcome back to another reaction video
uh this is something i saw on five
pillars um and
i was a bit taken back by it because
the way the video starts um it's it's
like your happy-go-lucky
caucasian family you know and it turns a
bit bitter towards the end so i'm going
to get into the video so this is a
missionary couple
moving to egypt with their kids and
here's their introduction to the country
to their religion to and basically
everything that they're about hi friends
and family it's the birdie kids over
here
angela mark and lucas josiah and lyanna
and we just thought we would do a quick
little tour of our new place here in
egypt
hopefully we can utilize this space when
i see that i just see it's like a
typical white family
and it's a it's just i don't i would
never ever think about what's about what
they're about to say
never because the way they start is just
hi we moved into a new house you know
check our
you know our living room you know our
view up here bro
look what happens with something maybe
make a prayer mickey
make it a rooftop
prayer worship who knows we'll see what
god
leads us to and what you're here right
now so when he's talking about god
and you can say he's a man of god even
though if we say with this we differ in
the
uh beliefs but you can see he's a man of
god and
but let's see what happens with this man
of god it's demons muslim prayer
it's about noon time right now
i was expecting for him to cry by the
way and i'm trying to hear it
so
we pray against it obviously because it
is
we pray against it together yeah
oppressing for a lot of christians here
but we just stand against it
against this propaganda and against the
false religion
and against this you know
this period it gets worse but let's just
add up on that here
so he's saying this propaganda we pray
against this
and the oppression of the christians
you're egyptian
right when he's talking about christians
have been oppressed yeah
there isn't a vanguard enough i don't
know how you can relate he was saying
that that was oppressive
okay okay he was saying that's
oppressive and he was saying that's
propaganda yeah yeah
okay so now you're from egypt yeah
if i'm not mistaken there are coptic
christians oh yeah oh yeah how many
so according to census there is 10 of
the population now
i reckon the egyptian population is
probably over 100 million probably 110
million
okay even though the census data is
probably less than that or the data that
they have the government data is less
than that but it's probably about 110
maybe going on 220 million
so if we if we assume that that's 10 of
that it's probably about 20
12 million so say 12 13 million copts
okay 11 million okay okay so now as far
as i know one of the oldest churches
are in egypt well no the the the the
oriental
um orthodox church which is the coptic
kind of church is one of the oldest uh
churches
and this and look when islam spread to
egypt yeah okay
with us uh when it spread to egypt
the biggest indication that what these
people say that islam spread by the
sword and it
forced people to convert by the at the
point of the sword
that now the biggest um living testimony
to the contrary
is the continued existence of the
egyptian coptic
people up until 2021 when we're doing
this video
in other words if it was true that these
people were forced to convert why is
there such
a healthy minority of egyptian copts
that
that still exists in egypt and that they
weren't forced to become muslim until
this day and their places of worship are
still intact
no doubt about that if you go to egypt
if you go to cairo there's a place
called chobra
which basically is for all intents and
purposes a coptic
area and all of that not only to be
honest
not only are they there but they are
protected
they are very much protected you know
and their special protection
so the assumption of uh oppression
i mean i'm not saying that they weren't
uh there weren't like any minority group
there haven't been oppression in history
muslims yeah
of course of course but the the fact of
the matter is
i mean he's saying that the athan is
oppressive so this is yeah and there is
and you know what's very ironic
is this is a missionary couple which
they're hostile they're choosing to move
to this country
you know what if you find it so like
he's talking about the devil or
something why are you going to live in
the house of the devil
exactly let's get there look let's see
what's the spirit of the devil he
basically made his throne here and he
makes it known like
three times a day that he is here so he
says three times a day
actually it's five times and that's a
very basic fact of islam yeah which
shows you the ignorance of this guy like
if you don't even know
there's a stop at the colleen if you
don't even know that muslims pray five
times a day and you're meant to be
locating into a muslim country for
missionary purposes
so if you are locating it's like it's
like going to uh if i if we're doing
dawah to go into locating to a christian
country
for missionary for missionary purposes
and we don't even know that
what the trinity constitutes exactly
it's like the most basic belief about
islam
how many times do muslims pray and
therefore how many times should you hear
that then a day
is five any child in any re classroom
will tell you that
so this guy i think he's by the way by
the look of his
facial expression i think really what's
going on here bro
is this guy is actually threatened he's
threatened by it yeah and i think
he's listening to him thinking is this
the truth and he's shocked by it and he
is
threatened he's clearly threatened by it
because this
this facial expression here for me and
i'm not trying to psychoanalyze the guy
nobody's true but
it's one of it's like contrivance it's
not a genuine authentic expression it's
like he's putting it on it's a fake
and he's doing it because him and his
wife are there and they maybe feel a bit
threatened about this
because they're thinking well these
people take their religion very
seriously we only do this once every
week
they do it five times a day and it is
very frustrating because a lot of people
even non-muslim they will say you know
what one thing we give to the muslims
they are damn consistent and they
practice their faith and now with the
downfall of christianity in the west and
we're looking at some stats where
you know they are losing like 66 million
there's some figures actually i don't
know the exact figures i'll tell you
you know i know the figures bro hijab i
do know the figures like you know
the the 2001 census data in the uk yes
uh said i believe it was
i believe in see non-native women as
well okay no no no
2001 from 2001 to 2011 there was a 20 22
depreciation okay so wow so i think it
was 70 something and then it became 50
like percent according to british
attitude surveys which are probably like
the gold standard
uh in terms of anticipating census data
because the census data
is is strong yeah we've got census by
the way in 2021
this year what's anticipated is that
it's going to be below 50
so 45 christians in this country i'm
thinking to myself bro you know the
english language they know the english
language
if you're afraid to see the downfall of
christianity why are you going to egypt
go to england bro no no well that's the
thing all right
stay in america well i think that's
where the missionary aim is now
imagine bro there's never been a 22
percent
depreciation like that you know that
we're talking about millions of people
in a span of 10 years that decided to
become irreligious
in england and well it explains and it's
happening in the us as well well why
don't you go there well those are
preaching there well those figures
explain this facial expression i mean if
i heard those figures
as a religious man like him i would have
the same figure especially with
someone that's supposed to be a godly
man for him to come out there go to a
muslim country in a hostile manner
instead of doing a bloody i thought he's
going to do like mtv cribs you know this
is my crib
come in there and just disrespectful and
it's it's disgusting if you look at the
comment section he's actually
that's what allah says in the quran
about the christian people of the book
are not the same because there's
people in there christians are actually
refuting them saying you're supposed to
be a godly man
you're there your son is there and
you're here talking about
the satan has established throne here i
mean
let's get this right for a second what
are you talking about here there's been
thousands of prophets that have been
sent
and even in your biblically yeah all of
them have confessed one thing
worship god alone yeah worship god alone
can you imagine the consistency and they
come and say oh your prophet came and
changed things hold on a second
you've had hundreds of prophets so let's
say whatever all of them came with a
consistent message
god is worship god alone worship god
alone don't associate partners
and then comes along paul or somebody
else he changes the whole diction flips
it on his head
and you're coming and telling us that
prophet muhammed it came to change the
the the whole thing he didn't the
prophet peace be upon him came to
be consistent and to turn you guys back
to the
actual narrative original yes and you're
here talking about satan the biggest
thing that satan wants to do and achieve
is for you to worship other than god and
as a christian man
you claim to be against idol worship or
whatever it may be and you are here
deifying jesus
you know and you're here you dare to
come a monotheistic religion
he was calling to the oneness of god and
satan has established throne and look
how uncomfortable you are let's just
watch it
one more thing as well bro like this has
so much colonial implications
yes like with in egypt there's been so
many european countries that have come
in and tried to
stick their hands in business we've had
the napoleonic wars and
we see with napoleon in the late 1700s
when they went into egypt bro you see
the orientalist stuff and edward said
actually documents this in his book
orientalism
they try to change the culture they try
and educate people do their own
propaganda
bro like at the end of the day and then
the obviously the british come into
egypt as well and stay there for a very
long time
you know so we're talking this is just
an extension of that you you have this
attitude of snobbery and coming over and
you think you're
you think you've got something that we
that we need one night bro like with
would you respect the quran
actually deals with christianity and by
virtue of historical necessity
the bible cannot deal with the quran so
all these muslim people that you think
you're going to
go convert they've heard it all before
yeah i'm sorry they've
they've by necessity they have heard all
of your arguments and the quran refutes
everything that you're going to bring
so good luck in egypt yeah yeah egypt is
is one of the hardest places to try and
get convicts exactly especially if the
islam bothers you spanish
so thanks for coming along on my little
tour i hope it kind of gave you a little
glimpse
damn gave a glimpse of your bloody not
forget your life indeed it gave me a
glimpse of
what you guys really are and this is
very appalling and i think
it shows and i think a lot of christians
watching this are going to be very
disturbed by this video
to see that fellow godly people are
there preaching nothing but hate and
these are the same people
who repeat the cycle of jesus's love
this
is unbelievable you know and he's there
like like you said you know he thinks
he's
not like you know yeah i've come here
who the hell do you think you are right
like i said
i i really do think i think they're
friends and you know why
do you know what's the best evidence of
that you remember that bbc report when
she went
you know what let's play it let's be
honest yeah remember what i'm talking
about you know the saudi arabia one
exactly
yeah and she heard the adhan and bro it
has like an effect on you and so she
started crying
[Music]
it's such an incredible sight and sound
that i find myself completely overcome
look she's a very genuine authentic
person and
she and she has a very natural response
to it and
and it's threatening bro for someone who
wants to proper propagate something
which is other than islam
when you feel that bro it's like wow
this thing is real it's not just
it's not just a theoretical thing
spiritually you feel like
hit by it of course and the thing is i
think this other guy i think will end on
this beautiful note like seeing this
lady there and she's crying it just
shows you when a person's soul
is pure and the fitra is still open yeah
and it's not
clouded with this evilness this this
this arrogant behavior
just for them
if that is not polluted you can see that
when this look how many youtubers
non-muslims do
where they genuinely cry because it's
not something that guy recently was his
name neil what's his name
from taken he even said it himself he's
like maybe islam is the army yeah
it's threatening bro trust me yes can
you imagine and the thing is
it's when you hear that bro come on
anybody that has that even if you are
not muslim you say
that is heartwarming at least you can
say is
that is heartwarming you would never say
satan so i think what it shows is that
maybe he's got satan inside him he's
maybe possible
by the way actually actually he's
projecting it bro you know
then is one of the things if you say and
someone is possessed yeah
it it frightens [ __ ] because there's
there's a hadith about saying that
and then the devil scores yeah one light
that makes perfect sense yeah
he explains it all he needs okay and i
think that brother sisters lesser than
positive or not inshallah we started
with a negativity but with this
beautiful
adhan and this lady crying so apparently
it shows you the beauty of islam
and how threatened people are by um i'm
not even going to say meredith because
adam is powerful
the the how powerful that is that the
very enemies who are hostile towards
islam
are crumbling on rooftops wow yeah i
like that yeah
until next time
that's good crumbling on rooftops so
there it is
when did you come up with that were you
thinking of that when you were praying
or something
that was hilarious